So, what I want to talk about
today in lecture is a game
theoretic notion known as The
Prisoners' Dilemma, which can
be used to characterize a
structure that is brought out
both in Book Two of Plato's
Republic and in chapter 13 of
Hobbes' Leviathan.
And the purpose of introducing
you to this way of thinking
about questions is exactly what
we have been doing all
semester long.
It's taking a traditional set
of philosophical issues and
asking how it is that another
discipline's methodology can
shed light on those questions
in a complementary way.
So you'll recall at the
beginning of the last lecture
that I started off with a quote
from the beginning of
Book Two of Plato's Republic
when Glaucon is answering
Socrates' challenge to
articulate the nature and
origins of justice--the nature
and origins of, roughly
speaking, pro-social behavior.
And I pointed out that the claim
that Glaucon makes there
takes the form as follows. "They
say that to do justice--
injustice is naturally good,
to suffer injustice is bad,
but that the badness of
suffering so far exceeds the
goodness of doing it that
those who have done and
suffered injustice and taken
both but lack the power to do
it and avoid suffering, decide
that it's profitable to come
to an agreement with each other
neither to do injustice
nor suffer it."
And we illustrated that with
the example of the two
shepherds, one of whom steals
another's horses and gains a
certain amount of pleasure from
it, but not as much as
the displeasure that the
stolen fellow receives
likewise when the second
steals the first.
So both of them end up in a
situation with less utility
than they would have if they
were cooperating and they come
together and form some
sort of pact.
Glaucon continues with the
passage that I also read you
last class.
He says, "Justice is
intermediate between the best
and the worst. The best is to
do injustice without paying
the penalty.
The worst is to suffer
it without being
able to take revenge.
Justice is a mean between
these two extremes."
But I didn't read you the
sentence that follows that,
which is one on which we'll be
focusing in today's lecture.
Because Glaucon continues by
pointing out that on his view,
and it will turn out, if you
were thinking of justice as
this kind of coordination,
on anybody's view
mathematically--
can I ask one of the TFs to
fix the door so that it
doesn't slam as people
walk in?
What he says is, "People value
it not because it is a good,
but because they are too weak
to do injustice with
impunity."
Someone who has the power to
harm another without being
harmed himself, someone who
has the power to do this,
however, wouldn't make an
agreement with anyone not to
do injustice in order
not to suffer it.
"For him, that would
be madness."
So Glaucon has given us an
argument that we're going to
see again in a minute in
Hobbes that takes the
following form.
It is rational when you think
there is no choice but to
cooperate, to cooperate.
But if you think you can get
away with having the other
person cooperate while you act
in a non-cooperative fashion,
it would be insane for
you to cooperate.
It would be madness.
Hobbes makes exactly
the same point in
Chapter 13 of Leviathan.
You'll remember that he
articulates there the first
two laws of nature.
Laws of nature, remember, are
norms to which rational beings
qua rational beings are bound,
because they recognize that in
following those norms they
increase the likelihood of
preservation and flourishing
in their own lives.
So the first law of nature
is a two-part law.
It says seek peace if there's
a chance of obtaining peace,
and if there is not,
engage in war.
The second law of nature,
if you'll recall, also
articulates a conditional
commitment to giving up a
certain sort of freedom.
The second law of nature tells
you to be willing to lay down
your rights to the extent that
others are willing to do the
same, and to content yourself
with as much liberty against
others as they have
against you.
So again, as in the first law
of nature, the giving up of
rights is conditional
on others giving
up rights as well.
Like Glaucon, Hobbes gives voice
to the concern that this
may not be feasible.
He writes, "If other men will
not lay down their right as
well as he, there is no
reason for anyone to
divest himself of his.
For to do that would be to
expose himself to prey which
no man is bound to, rather than
to dispose himself to
peace."
We're going to be using the
clickers after the next slide,
so if you get your clickers
out you'll be
prepared for that.
Now, I know that some of you
in this class are economics
majors and some of you in this
class have taken game theory.
And to those of you, I apologize
in the way that I
apologize to the philosophy
majors for introducing you at
a basic level to Plato's
Republic.
But this is a resource that all
of us need to understand
the class, and I promise that
there are some actual games
that we'll be playing
in a few minutes.
So the Prisoners' Dilemma is a
way of representing in graphic
form the structure
to which both
Glaucon and Hobbes adverted.
And it involves representing a
pair of choices by a pair of
people on a two-by-two matrix.
So there is on the one hand an
individual, A, who faces two
possibilities for action.
The first is that she can behave
in a peaceful way, lay
down her rights to attack her
enemy and thereby give up a
certain kind of freedom.
Or she can reserve for herself
the right to war and thereby
produce in her challenger a
feeling of threat throughout.
Her counterpart, B,
faces exactly the
same pair of choices.
He can behave peacefully and lay
down his right to attack,
or he can reserve the pleasures
of war for moments
when he feels himself, either
preemptively or retaliatorily,
to need to engage in threatening
behavior.
Now what's important to notice
about the prisoners'--
Sorry.
So that gives us four
possibilities.
Either A and B can both behave
in peaceful fashion.
That is, they satisfy the
initial clause of Hobbes'
first law of nature.
They do the handshake of
Glaucon's challenge; they each
give up to the same amount of
what Hobbes talks about in the
second law of nature.
Or, they can both be in a state
of war with one another.
This is what Glaucon thinks will
naturally arise and what
Hobbes thinks is the case
in the state of nature.
Or it can be the case that A,
the letter on the left refers
to A, behaves peacefully,
whereas B behaves in a
war-like fashion.
Or it can be the case that A
behaves in a war-like fashion,
whereas B behaves in a
peace-like fashion.
Now what's important to notice
about the structure of The
Prisoners' Dilemma, is
that A has control
over which row obtains.
A can determine whether we're
in this row or this row.
But A has no control over
which column obtains.
B, by contrast, has control over
which column obtains, and
no control over which
row obtains.
B can determine whether we're on
the left hand column or the
right hand column, but B can't
determine through his direct
behavior whether we're in the
top row or the bottom row.
Now, I want to just start by
making sure that everybody has
understood the structure of
this problem, because as I
said I'm about to put some real
money on the line for
you, and I want to make sure
that when you make the
decision, you make it
understanding the
structure of the case.
So let me start by telling you
what A's preference structure
is with regard to outcome, and
then ask you with your
clickers to tell me
which choice is
rational for A to make.
So as we know from Glaucon,
everybody's first choice is to
reserve for themselves all the
rights, but to have their
opponent lay down his rights.
So A's first choice is that
A is war-like and B is
peace-like.
Everybody's fourth choice, as
Glaucon points out, is to be
stuck having laid down
their arms when their
enemy hasn't done so.
To be cooperating when their
enemy is failing to cooperate.
So that's A's fourth choice.
But as Glaucon and Hobbes both
point out, between the choice
of peace-peace and war-war, that
is, a state of nature or
a state of society where there's
been a mutual laying
down of rights, it is
everybody's second choice, in
particular A's second choice, to
be in a peaceful state and
A's third choice to be in
a state of total war.
So the question that I
want you to answer--
so the choice that A makes
is which row we're in.
A can put herself in a row where
she's either going to
get her second choice or
her fourth choice.
Or she can put herself in a row
where she's going to get
either her first choice
or her third choice.
That's the decision
A has to make.
Second or fourth choice, versus
first or third choice.
That's it.
So, question, if you'll take
out your clickers, is this.
Which choice, given
this matrix, is it
rational for A to make?
Is it rational for A to choose
row one, where she will get
either her second or fourth
choice, or is it rational for
A to choose row two, where
she'll get her
first or third choice?
OK.
So.
The 4% of you who want to punish
the guy who didn't do
things that are wrong, to cut
up the guy who showed up
naively at the hospital, and to
choose the dominated choice
in a prisoners' dilemma matrix
are here with us always.
Those of you reading psychology
articles who wonder
why it is that in doing
statistical analysis one needs
to leave room for experimental
error, can see over and over
in our classroom environment
why that is so.
But 96% of the answers brought
out what is inherently the
structure of this situation,
namely, that given a choice
between peace, where A will
get her second or fourth
choice, and war, will she get
her first or third, the
obvious thing for A to do is
to choose the lower row.
So now we have A's
decision made.
What is rational for A to do
is to choose the lower row.
The situation for B is of course
exactly symmetric.
B gets to choose the column,
so B can choose--
B's first choice would be that
A is peaceful while B is
war-like, B's fourth choice is
that A is war-like, while he's
peace-like.
B's second choice is peace-peace
and B's third
choice is war-war.
So just to check again and let's
see if I can get rid of
that residual 4%,
let's try again.
What is the rational
choice for B to
make in this situation?
If you do a good job on
this, we'll go to
the real money one.
What is the rational choice
for B to make in this
situation, given that peace will
give him his second or
fourth choice and war will give
him his first or third?
So let's see how the numbers
come out this time for us.
Three, two, one second, and--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Ha, ha, ha.
All right.
Excellent.
So there we go.
Ninety-two percent of you on
eternity on the internet have
given a rational answer,
and 8% of you forever,
anonymously, will be known
to have put yourself
in situation one.
So the structure of The
Prisoners' Dilemma with regard
to B is also that the column
that is rejected is the
peaceful column.
So what we have is a situation
where A determines the row,
sorry, where B determines the
column, and chooses the
war-like column.
A determines the row and chooses
the war-like row.
And the result of this is that
it is a stable situation in
dilemmas of this kind that
everybody ends up with their
third choice.
Now, the structure that we've
just described in the context
of the Glaucon-Hobbes style
social contract question is of
course a structure that emerges
over and over again.
Any choice situation where the
person choosing the column has
an array like this, and the
person choosing the row has an
array like this.
That is, any situation where
there is asymmetric first and
fourth choices and symmetric
second and third choices, will
end up stably putting people in
this situation where they
both end up with their
third choice.
So, for example, if
we put people--
we're police officers and we
put criminals in a dilemma,
this is why it's called The
Prisoners' Dilemma --
where we incentivize unilateral
confession over
staying silent, it will turn out
that both prisoners will
be motivated to confess, ending
up with their third
choice rather than what would
have been their second, both
staying silent.
If we are in a nuclear arms
race with another country
where mutual disarmament would
leave both countries with a
peace dividend, it will
nonetheless be the case that
the fear of the other party
defecting and the fear of
perhaps ending up in one of
these cells, will push both
parties to the third choice.
Third choice.
If we are in the situation
described at the beginning of
today's reading, Hume's story
of two individuals, both of
whom would benefit if they put
in the effort to drain the
swamp outside of their field,
neither of whom wants to be
the only one to do it,
you will get a
non-cooperative situation.
And you face analogous
situations with any sort of
cooperative scenario where
multiple people cooperating
would produce an outcome that
was beneficial for the group
as a whole, but no individual
wants to be the one who takes
on an undue burden.
So vaccination is another
example of
a prisoners' dilemma.
There's a certain low risk
associated with vaccinating
your child or yourself
against a disease.
There's a very, very low risk
that the child will get very
ill and a somewhat moderate risk
that the child will have
slight illness.
On the other hand, if nobody
engaged in vaccination, we
would be much worse off.
And, in fact, the motivation
not to
vaccinate would dissipate.
So more generally, prisoners'
dilemmas arise when the
cooperative situation
is dominated
by the defect situation.
And the puzzle that we will
talk about after we run
through a few more examples is
how, if at all, it's possible
to move from this cell
to this cell.
So as I pointed out, prisoners'
dilemmas arise in
asymmetric cases where one-sided
cooperation is the
most costly option, where
one-sided defection is the
most beneficial option, where
two-sided defection is
somewhat costly, and where
two-sided defection
[correction: cooperation]
is somewhat beneficial.
Now, how are we going to
do that in this class?
Here's what I came up with.
This is the classroom dilemma,
and it's for real.
It's for real.
The money's right here and I
have a list of the names of
the students who are actually
going to get money from this
for each dilemma that we play.
We're playing three right now.
One of you, and I'll tell you
afterwards, will actually get
one of the following payoffs.
If you choose one, and the
majority of the class chooses
one, you will get $15.
If you choose one, and the
majority of the class chooses
one, you will get $15.
Here's a twenty right
here, and I will
make change for you.
If you choose two, and the
majority of the class chooses
one, you will get $50.
Fifty dollars.
I'm betting on game
theory here.
If you choose one and
the majority of the
class chooses two--
I wanted to put in a
penalty here but I
couldn't ask you for money.
So you'll just get nothing.
And if you choose two and the
majority of the class chooses
two, you will get $5.
Now, just to point out that I am
good on my word, Sarah Cox,
are you here today?
Sarah Cox.
Sarah Cox, did you get
$5 from me on March--
I'm sorry, on February 15?
Yeah.
Sarah Cox did get $5.
And looking back over my notes
made me realize that I never
selected somebody for the second
prize, and March 22 and
24 were last week, so Tara
Abraham, are you here?
Wow.
Tara Abraham, you will get
either, you will actually get
$6, because I'm just going
to assume that
you were in the 97%.
So come up after class
and get your money.
OK.
So I want to tell you that I'm
serious, and here's the
classroom dilemma.
Here it is.
If you choose one, you will
get either $15 or zero
dollars, depending on what the
majority of the class does.
If you choose two-- swear,
I'm totally serious--
you will get either $50 or $5,
depending on what the rest of
the class does.
I mean it.
Start clicking.
Only eight of you?
Nobody wants the money?
I'm going to start the timer.
Don't miss your chance.
This is real money.
There is a list of names
right here, for real.
Those two people that I called
are really here.
These are not plants.
If you're not here somebody
else will get the money.
So bid away.
You have 10, 9, 8, let's
see whether game
theory is on my side.
All right, let's see
what we got.
OK.
The majority of the class chose
two, so there I am.
And the individual selected
is Charles Holmes.
Charles Holmes, are you here?
Charles Holmes is not getting
what Charles Holmes might have
gotten, which is either
zero or $5--
well, Charles Holmes is getting
zero dollars, but not
as a result of this.
Sello Lekalakala are you here?
Sello Lekalakala Sello
Lekalakala Did you give an
answer, Sello, of one or two?
You gave an answer of two.
Sello, after class, you may
come up and get $5.
Let's try it again.
Let's see whether I am going
to have to pay my $50.
OK?
I was betting that I would have
to give $5, and I did.
Notice, you guys, you ended up
in the bottom right hand
corner of the prisoners'
dilemma.
OK?
Let's try it again.
Same game.
Trying it again.
I'm really risking, right?
Go ahead.
Do what you can.
Try to get your $50.
Give it your best shot.
All right.
Forty-nine of you.
Let me start the timer,
and let's see how the
numbers come out.
Let's see in our 4, 3, 2, 1
second live for television
audiences, 68 and 32.
OK, so once again the majority
has put us in two.
So let's see whether the victor,
what the victor is
going to get.
Either $50 or $5.
Sorry, either zero or $5.
The winner this time
is Helen Wang.
Helen Wang, are you going
to get zero, or $5?
Are you here, Helen?
OK.
Helen, did you give--
are you getting zero
dollars or $5?
You're getting $5.
Excellent.
All right.
I'm out another $5.
Let's try it one more time.
Game theory on my side.
Guys, you're in the bottom
right hand corner.
What's up?
This is the prisoners'
dilemma for you.
Let's try it one more time.
Which do you choose?
Same bet all over again.
OK?
I have all the money
right here.
I stole it actually from my
son's Bar Mitzvah folder.
I don't have cash at home
but he had a lot.
All right.
But I will fortunately be able
to pay him back most of it, so
he'll be grateful.
OK.
So let's see how our
numbers are going.
Forty-nine of you
up there again.
Ten, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
Let's see whether I'm going
to lose some money.
Fifty-four percent.
You're getting closer.
Ah ha.
I put it up three times,
thinking very, very hard that
I didn't want to put
it up a fourth.
OK.
So the winner this time,
Jared Jones.
Jared Jones, are you here?
Jared Jones, OK.
Jared, do you get zero
dollars or $5?
You picked two.
So once again $5, and we are
in the bottom right hand
corner of the prisoners'
dilemma.
OK, dudes, you missed out on
the peace dividend, right?
You would have been better off
if somehow we could have ended
up in the fifteen-fifteen
cell.
And the cooperation dividend,
which was unavailable to you
because of course this is a big
room and you're seated in
rows and you couldn't collude
and there were no enforcement
mechanisms. The cooperation
dividend was
unavailable to you.
What's the cooperation
dividend look like?
Well, it looks like this.
Here are our two shepherds in
the state of nature and each
of them grows a garden.
But because it's the state of
nature, the green guy goes
over to the red guy's garden and
steals a tomato, and the
red guy, angry at the green guy,
goes over to the green
guy's garden and smashes it
up with his pitchfork.
So the green guy says, I don't
want the red guy smashing up
my garden with his pitchfork.
I'm going to put a fence around
my garden, and he uses
his effort to do that.
And the red guy says, I don't
want the green guy stealing my
tomatoes, and he puts a fence
around his garden.
If, however, they had somehow
been able to cooperate, to
make some sort of agreement
whereby they would keep their
hands off the other fellow's
garden, instead of putting
that effort into building the
fences, they could have put
their effort into what Hobbes
calls the features of
commodious living.
So the green fellow could've had
a beautiful flower garden
that attracts hummingbirds, and
the red fellow could have
developed a device that allows
him to predict the motion of
the planets.
When we don't have to expend
energy on things like
protecting our property, we have
extra energy left over
for things like commodious
living.
And just to remind you where
that fits in the context of
things, this is Hobbes'
explanation for why it is
rational for us to engage
in a social contract.
What I want to do now is to
introduce you to a second
notion closely related to that
of The Prisoners' Dilemma.
Namely, The Problem
of the Commons.
And I'll give you three examples
of that, and then
we'll get to play
one more game.
And there's real money on the
line there, so let me say I
have a lot left over from
the last round.
So here's The Problem
of the Commons.
Tragedy of the Commons.
So suppose you live around a
beautiful green area and you
and your fellow shepherds
each have a cow.
So you put your cow out on
the pasture to graze, and
everything's going fine.
Now there's a nice big pasture
there, and in fact you would
be better off if you had
not one but two cows.
So you and each of your fellow
shepherds gets a second cow,
and puts it out in
the pasture.
But of course if two cows were
good, three cows are better.
So you and each of your fellow
shepherds puts your extra cow
out, and now you have
three cows apiece.
Three cows great, four
cows, super duper.
Each of you gets a fourth cow,
puts it out to pasture.
And the result, if the clicker
will work, the result is that
there is no more space
left to graze.
The pasture gets destroyed.
So scarce resources become
depleted through The Tragedy
of the Commons.
Likewise, it's now the
industrial revolution.
We've made it past our
shepherd days.
You and your fellow
industrialists each create one
polluting plant,
and here it is.
Putting out a little
bit of pollution.
One polluting plant good, two
polluting plants better, so
out you go, and there's
the profit.
No idea why these are going
non-cooperatively.
There we go.
You got your third plant
super fast on
account of the clicker.
And out comes the fourth
plant for each of you.
Result, the entire environment
is polluted.
Each of you did the thing that
was rational, but the
coordinated effect of your
actions gave you a wildly
sub-optimal result, an
environment full of pollution.
Notice that we can think of
everybody in this class'
favorite problem, the problem
of procrastination, in light
of The Tragedy of the Commons.
Suppose this is a representation
of the
hours in your day.
And this is your 9 a. m. self,
and this is your noon self,
and this is your 6 p.m. self,
and this is your 10 p.m. self.
Now, your 9 a.m. self and your
noon self and your 6 p.m.
self, and your evening self,
all want to play a round of
Angry Birds.
But, you know what?
One round good, two
rounds better.
Two rounds, good, three
rounds great.
Three rounds great, four rounds
super, and all of a
sudden you've spent your day
playing Angry Birds.
So the structure that The
Tragedy of the Commons
confronts us with is not just
one of depletion of resources.
It's not just one of pollution
of the environment and other
sorts of degradation that result
from actions that are
individually non-problematic,
but as an aggregate, lead to
bad outcomes.
It's also a way of thinking
about one of the questions
we've asked ourselves over
and over in this course.
Which is, how do we structure
our lives in such a way that
our long-term goals are
the ones we achieve?
And when I say I'm not kidding
that the trope of the
Republic, that the individual
and society mirror one another
in important ways, here's
another place
that I'm not kidding.
So let's play our own Tragedy
of the Commons game.
So here's how our Tragedy
of the Commons
game is going to go.
OK.
So the deal is this.
Each of you can decide whether
in this game, if you are the
name called, and I have more
names on my list, if you are
the name called, whether you
will take a reward of $1.
If so, push one.
Whether you will take
a reward of $2, in
which case, push two.
Or whether you will take--
I'm sorry, of $10, push two.
Or whether you will take a
reward if called, of $50.
Fifty dollars.
There's a name on this list.
There's roughly a hundred
clickers, you have a one in
100 chance of $50 if you
choose three.
But here's the deal.
If the total requested is less
than $150, I'll reward the
winning student with
the amount that
he or she has requested.
But if the total requested,
and I will say, I thought
there would be more clickers
than there are, this is a
riskier game than I
meant myself to be
playing, but we will see.
If the total requested is more
than $150, Tragedy of the
Commons, bank goes bust, too
many requests, no reward.
OK?
So, the game is there,
22, 23, 24--
I'm going to hold off.
I want a lot of responses
to this game.
Let's see how these
numbers come in.
All right, I am going
to play fair.
I'm going to start
count down now.
Ten, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
You only came in at
85 responses?
I may have to do some math.
No, I don't have to
do some math.
Busted.
You guys bankrupted the bank.
There's no way, right?
I mean, at 30 times 10, you're
way over the $150.
Greedy, greedy, greedy.
Who didn't get their dollar?
Kyle Cooper, I'm sorry.
You would've gotten some money
and you got nothing.
All right.
Now, that's an interesting
psychological question, why
it's worse to have gotten
nothing that way than the way
that all the rest of
you got nothing?
OK.
So, what's going on in The
Tragedy of the Commons is what
you see here.
That is, each of you did what
was individually rational, I
mean, 18% percent of you
went for the big money.
But 38% of you went for $10.
Only 45% of the students chose
the option that was possible
for everybody to take.
You violated the categorical
imperative.
All right.
Well, that's life.
But the question is, now that
we've presented ourselves with
these two versions of the
puzzle, The Prisoners' Dilemma
on the one hand and The Tragedy
of the Commons on the
other, what kind of strategies
there are for escape.
And in the last 10 minutes of
lecture, I just want to talk
through at a very general level
what kinds of strategies
are available.
So remember, the
issue is this.
Three out of three times, you
all ended up in the bottom
right hand corner of The
Prisoners' Dilemma.
You ended up with your third
choice rather than what could
also potentially have been a
stable outcome, your second.
And in The Tragedy of the
Commons, you all, as a result
of your expression of rational
self-interest, ended up in a
situation where, as an
aggregate, you were worse off.
So what do we need to do to
escape this situation?
We need somehow to structure the
decision situation so that
we either decrease the relative
utility of the
sub-optimal behavior, or
increase the relative utility
of the optimal behavior.
That is, somehow we want to make
it the case that B isn't
moving us over to the right,
and that A isn't moving us
down to the bottom.
That's the only way for us to
get out of this situation.
So we have various mechanisms
that are available to us for
doing this.
We can introduce some sort of
penalty or reward for the
asymmetric cells in a way that
will either make the one less
appealing, or the four
less repulsive.
So that the siren call of the
first choice doesn't beckon B
in the same way to defect, and
the fear of the fourth choice
doesn't beckon A to defect.
The result of having done this
will be to create the
potential for some sort
of stable, sustainable
equilibrium at the
preferred cell.
At our two-two, rather
than our three-three.
So what sort of mechanisms are
available in this context?
Well, the first place we might
look is to external penalties
and external rewards.
So one thing that we can do is
simply to incentivize the
cooperative behavior.
We can do it with material
incentives, like increased
money or goods, things
that are valuable.
We can do it with social
incentives.
We can have status markers
associated with cooperation.
We can bring reputation
costs into play.
And when we play prisoners'
dilemma games in sections next
week, you'll have an opportunity
to try out all of
these things.
Or we can induce certain kinds
of personal incentives.
We can increase your freedoms or
your privileges as a result
of your having cooperated.
And with respect to each of
these kinds of incentives,
there are counterparts
which are penalties.
So, there can be material
penalties associated with
non-cooperation.
We can decrease your
amount of money.
We can take away some
of your goods.
There can be social penalties
associated with
non-cooperation.
You could face a decrease in
status or a decrease in
reputation.
Or, there could be personal
costs associated with
non-cooperation.
Decreases in freedom, or
decreases in your privileges.
So these are the sorts of
penalties and rewards that can
be imposed in such a way to
change the incentive structure
of The Prisoners' Dilemma.
But in addition to there being
different sorts of incentives
and penalties, one of the things
that's important to
recognize in thinking about this
question is that there
can also be different sorts of
mechanisms of enforcement that
are put into play.
And this will ultimately bring
us to why it is that Hobbes
thinks it's required that we
have the sort of external
force that the government
provides.
So we might on the one hand have
mechanisms of enforcement
that are intrapersonal.
We might create within ourselves
certain kinds of
attitudes that cause us to
cultivate cooperative behavior.
Conscience is an instance of an
intrapersonal solution to
coordination problems. You
internalize social norms, it
becomes part of your
self-conception, and as a
result, you behave in
pro-social ways.
It could be in the context of
The Tragedy of the Commons.
The Prisoners' Dilemma.
It could be in the context of
your own cultivation of habits
to overcome that intrapersonal,
cross-temporal
prisoners' dilemma that we all
face with regard to the
temptations of Angry Birds.
It could be some sort of
informal, interpersonal,
implicit or explicit schema.
So, for example, you might
adopt a strategy of
cooperating in the first round
of a prisoners' dilemma game,
and then, following the lead
of whatever your co-player
does, in subsequent rounds
of the game.
That, as you know from your
reading, is called the
tit-for-tat strategy.
And a supplementary reading,
which I will post for you,
given the sort of war theme
that has run through the
course, is a wonderful piece
by Robert Axelrod about the
evolution of a tit-for-tat
strategy in trench warfare
during World War I.
And that will be
up later this afternoon.
So sometimes informal
cooperative strategies arise,
and either implicitly or
explicitly people engage in
relatively stable rounds
of cooperation.
We can put into place formal,
interpersonal, formal
impersonal, institutional
structures.
Things like laws, and the
state, where there's in
position a regulation from
an outside force.
And we can finally put in
place various kinds of
technological controls.
Turning off the wireless
Internet on your computer.
Setting up the missiles during
the Cold War so that they fire
without human intervention
under certain situations.
And those two can serve the
function of enforcement.
So the ways of getting out of
The Prisoners' Dilemma, The
Problem of the Commons,
are manifold.
And they make use of virtually
all of the sorts of
considerations that
we've looked at
in class this semester.
What I want to close with is
by letting you see how much
more clearly thinking about
things in this way has, I
hope, enabled you to understand
the final bit of
Hobbes that we read for
Tuesday's class.
So you'll recall I gave
you the first and
second laws of nature.
That the first law of nature
said, make peace where
possible, reserve war
where necessary.
And the second said, lay down
your rights exactly to the
extent that others are willing
to lay down theirs.
The third law of nature, says
Hobbes, is to perform your
covenants, but he points out
that you will be unable to
follow this law that
self-interest demands if you
face the live possibility that
the other party will renege.
Because if that happens you
will move from your second
choice to your fourth choice.
And no one wants to
end up there.
So, says Hobbes, in order to
have covenants which will
allow you to thrive and flourish
and gain the benefits
of cooperation, there
must be some sort of
enforcement in place.
And what Hobbes suggests there
must be is a coercive power
that compels men equally to
the performance of their
covenants by the terror of some
punishment greater than
the benefit they expect by the
breach of their covenants.
That is, Hobbes is articulating
in the selections
that we read from chapter 15
of Leviathan, one of the
strategies, which by
mathematical analysis of the
case, we realized would be
sufficient to move people from
the three-three cell
to the two-two one.
So what we'll look at next week
are two different kinds
of justification for various
kinds of social structure.
We'll look at John Rawls'
appeal to our notions of
fairness, and Robert Nozick's
discussion of
the notion of liberty.
And the four of you to whom I
owe money are welcome to come
up now to obtain it.